what do you hate about men in the gym
what is it what is it so there's a bunch
here i'm just going to read a few that's
we've got women who want women gyms and
nothing
this is i absolute this is the first one
i absolutely hate when men care more
about taking selfies than about working
out i have seen this i can't for some
reason it's more like when you see a guy
doing the selfie game it just it's just
a little more nauseating than the women
doing the selfie game i don't know why
guys in my building all the time like
doing this and then the i'm just like i
can't guys it's not a good look i i just
i don't think it's good like do you
think it's good look for men to be
patient yeah no it's not we're telling
you straight we're trying to help you
all right this is great i was at the gym
the other day walked into the weight
room and was hit with a cloud of sweat
bo
guys are gross i hate it when they act
like the whole weightlifting area is
their domain and they're allowed to
smell like garbage put on some deodorant
and don't fart men don't fart while
you're on the treadmill next to me and
act like no one can tell where the
stench is coming from you know you've
all done it all this being said it's
gross to smell overpowering overpowering
cologne while working out too so
basically listen man
i've seen this before too i have seen it
men eat i don't know do you guys eat
like a ton of beans before you go to the
gym or something you're watching this
both men and women i've trained in my
lifetime i've probably encountered about
20 farts
20 farts
that's not even easily i mean it's
sometimes it's really aggressive maybe
even more but i will tell you right now
like i've had squat sessions i've had
deadlifting sessions that i'm like
i'll just pretend like nothing happens
don't just know like why are you
directing me from over here
see that's the difference between him
and i this is why i can't be a trainer
and i'll see why i say i can't run for
president i can't be a trainer because i
would be like dude what did you do did
you just fart that stinks stop doing
that i would say it i would this is why
no one would pay me tyler's like you're
just gonna have to stay here and have
your mic and that's gonna be it jed no
other options all the other career doors
are closed
all right but this person says blatantly
flexing in the mirror we did that
already um oh this woman doesn't like
when they ask to do sets with you and
share the same machine or equipment
actually do sex with you sets
i was like this is the first one i was
like wait wait wait anthony was like
to do sex and i thought you said sex and
then reps on them i was like wait sex
reps on the machine what's going on over
here you could do sex reps on a machine
i would not advise it that's the new
kinky tools that they're saying
you never know people do weird stuff on
the machines in the gym but i guess with
the sets is like
you got to load a lot of weight for the
guy then you got to take a lot of weight
like just let me do my set i'll be done
in two minutes and then you can load all
that is a little bit nice i will say
that
and one that is brought up constantly
about men is the grunting
apparently guys do all the grunting
all the time and i hear it all the time
and usually it's guys who are trying to
lift weight they're not supposed to be
lifting like it's too heavy it does
happen is that are you do you advise is
this something that they're suppo is
grunting advised by trainers well it's
funny because it's like
there's a there's a level of ground team
that's just like dude why do you have to
be granted like that but actually like
hard breathing and certain noises
actually helps you with with certain
lifts and actually helps you
i'm gonna start doing that yeah so
obviously there's a way to do it and
there's a level to do it oh no i'm
getting if you're out here going
screaming off the top of your lungs like
something's like dude why are you doing
this
you don't understand i've had i'll tell
you a little bit what do you think i'll
tell you a little bit about some of the
stuff so when i used to work remember
bali's yeah yeah that was my first uh
training job i remember working at
bally's and there's this one guy super
rode guy used to go to the machine
um all the time take that same own it
for like he would like own that machine
for a while where nobody can touch it
was his
screaming
to the top of his lungs like the whole
gym can hear from the front desk and i
remember like people would complain
about him all the time he would come and
start
he says i can do whatever i want i paid
membership i can scream at the top of my
lounge it'll go
start screaming everywhere and people
just like what's wrong with this guy and
i remember one day there was this old
lady
who um
she was just doing um pulldowns on the
tricep machine tries to pull downs on
the cable right next to him and he
literally yelled
and she turned around looked at him he
went up to her and went
at her face and she literally just
collapsed collapsed
and he's like what are you looking at
and she freaked out told the front desk
she was
she's like what's wrong with this guy
sometimes yeah this guy was on this guy
was on steroids this guy was
not knotted no no no no that was
probably the worst screaming experience
i hear it a lot i hear a lot of quality
experience myself sometimes they feel
like guy's grunt because they want you
to look to see that they're left in a
really heavy way and then you look and
you're like
then you look away but it could be an
eagle thing
and i had a woman in my gym um out here
that complained to a guy he was grunting
away and she was like can you stop doing
that and he was just like he didn't know
what to do it was awkward as all hell i
did watch though i did watch that
exchange go down
maybe they're grunting to mask a fart
oh man tyler you had to take me back to
that place don't fall to the gym oh
listen okay if you have to fart in the
gym because everybody has to fart
sometimes right maybe you did eat a big
sack of beans or some tacos on the way
there it happens go to an area of the
gym where no one is and stay there until
it dissipates don't be bringing it back
and then there's like a trail it's a
fart trail so i'll say that i'm not
gonna obviously i'm gonna say names but
i had this one individual i remember
this was one i think it was i think it
was la fitness already uh this one
individual was doing um squats and i
remember like we were talking and
ripped one and i was just like
step to the side
he's just hanging out he knew i and i
was just like okay cool
goes back on there goes on the squats
again rips another one
and i was just like god say hey buddy
you're good he's like yeah yeah he's
like he goes he's gonna go into the bar
and he's like
if you don't mind me um
i'm gonna go to the bathroom real quick
i felt so bad oh my god he literally had
charted
and it was literally all over his white
shorts at the bottom of the white shirt
oh my god imagine that oh my god [ __ ]
his pants and white shorts it was
bad
it was did he come back he did with
another pair of shorts on
another period but how do you like that
moment's gotta play over and over again
and i said and i said bro you're good
and you say no no i'm i'm good now it's
like okay okay you want to finish and
he's like yeah yeah i'm like okay the
deep shame i feel bad he's lucky he came
in at a down time it was like probably
like 3 30 4 p.m yeah rush hour hadn't
hit yet so that wasn't too many people
but
i just felt bad for him overall lord
well good for him for bringing another
pair of shorts good for him he didn't
have one um
and he brought up the black shorts adam
not the way he should have started
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here